En connaissant le désir de Daech de détruire des vies humaines,
détruire l'identité culturelle en est une extension naturelle.
Dans l'histoire, d'innombrables armées d'envahisseurs l'ont fait.
Nous savons que Daech profite du pillage des sites
mais ignorons à quel point.
Cela signifie que tout objet acheté aujourd'hui sur le marché
et venant du Moyen-Orient
pourrait financer le terrorisme.
Quand un site est pillé,
c'est comme si, pour un puzzle dont il manque 90% des pièces,
on l’obscurcissait pour le rendre impossible à distinguer.
C'est un important vol d'ancienne identité.
Nous savons qu'il se produit deux types de pillages :
le pillage fait par des criminels tels que Daech
et un pillage plus local fait par ceux ayant besoin d'argent.
Nous ferions tous la même chose pour nourrir notre famille ;
je ne reproche rien aux pilleurs locaux.
J'en veux aux intermédiaires, les trafiquants non éthiques
et un marché d'art international
qui exploitent des lois souvent ambiguës voire complètement inexistantes.
Nous savons qu'il y a de plus en plus de pillage à l'échelle mondiale
mais, actuellement, nous n'avons aucun outil pour l'arrêter.
Cela commence à changer.
Mon équipe et moi venons de finir une étude sur le pillage en Égypte.
Nous avons considéré les données open source
et avons cartographié tous les pillages en Égypte
de 2002 à 2013.
Nous avons des preuves de pillage et de destruction dans 267 sites
et avons cartographié plus de 200 000 lieux de pillages.
C'est stupéfiant.
En réunissant les données --
les lieux sont représentés ici.
Sur un site, le pillage augmente tous les ans : 2009, 2011, 2012 --
des lieux par centaines.
En réunissant les données,
nous avons découvert que, contrairement à l'idée populaire,
le pillage n'a pas augmenté en Égypte en 2011 après le Printemps arabe,
mais en 2009, après la récession mondiale.
Ainsi avec le big data, nous avons montré
que le pillage est principalement un problème économique.
Si nous ne réglons pas le problème,
tous les sites d’Égypte seront affectés par le pillage d'ici 2040.
Nous sommes donc à un moment déterminant.
Nous sommes la génération ayant les outils et les technologies
pour arrêter le pillage
mais nous ne travaillons pas assez vite.
Parfois, un site archéologique peut surprendre par sa résilience.
J'étais sur le terrain,
j'ai codirigé une mission commune avec le ministère égyptien des antiquités
sur un site appelé Lisht.
Le site date du Moyen Empire égyptien entre 2 000 et 1 750 ans avant JC.
Cela fait partie de la Renaissance de l’Égypte antique.
Après une période d'intenses conflits internes et de défis environnementaux,
l’Égypte s'est réunifiée
avec un renouveau incroyable en art, architecture et littérature.
C'est une des meilleures périodes à étudier en Égypte
car elle nous en apprend beaucoup sur comment survivre et prospérer
après des catastrophes.
Sur ce site, nous avions cartographié d'innombrables lieux de pillage.
Lisht est un site royal ;
des milliers de personnes y ont été enterrées
après vécu et travaillé à la cour du Pharaon.
Vous voyez l'avant-après ; il y a des douzaines de lieux de pillage.
Le nord de Lisht.
Voici le sud de Lisht, avant et après.
Lors de notre première visite,
nous voyions les tombeaux d'officiels hauts placés
qui avaient été pillés.
Laissez-moi remplacer cela dans son contexte.
Imaginez une zone de deux mètres sur deux pleine de cercueils, de bijoux
et d'incroyables statues.
Multipliez cela par mille.
C'est ce qui a été pris.
Au début de notre travail,
mon codirecteur égyptien, Mohamed Youssef, est venu me dire :
« Nous devons travailler sur ce tombeau.
Il a été attaqué par des pilleurs.
Si nous ne faisons rien, ils reviendront. »
J'étais d'accord mais ne croyais pas que nous trouverions quelque chose.
Je pensais que les pilleurs avaient tout volé.
Nous avons commencé à trouver des restes incroyables.
Regardez cette peinture, magnifique.
Nous avons trouvé des inscriptions gravées.
Et les titres du propriétaire du tombeau,
des titres comme « Gardien de l'Armée »,
« Gardien de la Trésorerie ».
J'ai commencé à espérer.
Peut-être trouverions-nous son nom.
Pour les Égyptiens, que leur nom perdure l'éternité
était le but.
Puis un jour,
ceci est apparu.
C'est le nom du propriétaire du tombeau : Intef.
Vous le voyez écrit en hiéroglyphes.
En travaillant avec mon équipe égyptienne,
nous avons rétabli le nom de quelqu'un vivant il y a 3 900 ans.
(Applaudissements)
En travaillant avec mes collègues égyptiens,
nous avons fêté ce moment de découverte commune.
Ce que nous faisions ensemble était bien et vrai.
Nous avons découvert cette fausse porte, intacte.
Dessus, nous avons lu l'histoire d'Intef et ses inscriptions.
Vous pouvez le voir assis ici.
J'ai réalisé que tout ce que je supposais des sites pillés
était faux.
Chaque jour, sur le site, nous travaillions avec 70 Égyptiens
en tant que collègues et amis.
Face à tant de haine et d'ignorance
envers ceux du Moyen-Orient,
à chaque instant passé sur le site, nous réclamions la paix.
En travaillant avec des gens qui ne vous aiment pas,
ne pensent pas ou ne parlent pas comme vous,
votre mission commune de découverte archéologique
efface toute différence superficielle.
Ce que j'ai appris,
c'est qu'en archéologie, il ne s'agit pas de la découverte
mais de ce que nous pouvons prouver être possible.
Parfois en voyageant, vous trouvez de la famille perdue depuis longtemps --
vous ne partagez pas de gènes
mais une entrée commune dans le livre de la vie.
Voici Omer Farrouk, mon frère.
Omer est un Gufti d'un village juste au nord de Louxor, appelé Guft.
Les Guftis font partie d'une tradition célébrée en Égypte.
Ils aident aux fouilles et au management d'équipe.
Il est mon chef d'exploitation et directeur financier.
Je ne pourrais pas travailler sans lui.
Un jour il y a plusieurs années, quand j'étais étudiante
et qu'Omer était un jeune Gufti ne parlant pas bien anglais,
nous avons appris par hasard
que nous étions nés la même année,
le même mois
et le même jour à six heures d'écart.
Des jumeaux.
(Rires)
Séparés par un océan mais pour toujours liés
car l’Égypte ancienne est notre mère.
Nous travaillerons toujours ensemble --
cela ne venait pas du cerveau
mais de la partie de mon âme qui sait que tout ne peut pas être expliqué.
(Arabe) Omer, mon frère,
je t'aimerai toujours.
(Anglais) Omer, mon frère, je t'aimerai toujours.
Juste avant ma première fouille en Égypte,
mon mentor, l'égyptologue très connu, le professeur William Kelley Simpson
m'a demandé de venir le voir.
Il m'a tendu un chèque de 2 000$
et a dit : « C'est pour couvrir tes dépenses.
Que ton aventure soit illustre cet été.
Un jour, tu feras ceci pour quelqu'un d'autre. »
Recevoir le TED Prize serait en partie pour le rembourser, avec intérêts --
(Rires)
pour la générosité et la gentillesse d'un être humain merveilleux.
Mon vœu.
Je souhaite que nous découvrions
les millions de sites archéologiques inconnus à travers le monde.
En créant au XXIe siècle une armée d'explorateurs mondiaux,
nous trouverons et protégerons l'héritage caché du monde
qui détient des indices sur la résilience et la créativité collectives humaines.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Comment allons-nous faire ?
Avec l'argent du TED Prize, nous allons mettre en place
une plateforme collaborative en ligne de sciences citoyennes
pour permettre à quiconque dans le monde de prendre part à la découverte
de sites archéologiques.
Nous ne sommes que quelques centaines d'archéologues spatiaux dans le monde.
Mon rêve est d'intéresser le monde
à nous aider à trouver des sites et à les protéger.
Vous vous inscrirez, créez un nom d'utilisateur --
notez que celui-ci en particulier est déjà pris.
(Rires)
Vous suivrez un tutoriel et vous travaillerez.
Je veux dire dès le début
que nous ne partagerons pas les données GPS ou de cartographie des sites.
Ce sera comme les données d'un patient humain,
nous ne révélerons pas leur localisation.
Ensuite vous recevrez une carte de 20 x 20 mètres ou 30 x 30 mètres
et vous chercherez des caractéristiques.
Mon équipe et moi avons traité
un gros volume de données satellites avec des algorithmes
afin que vous trouviez des choses et fassiez de la bonne science.
Ensuite vous regarderez.
Que voyez-vous ? Voyez-vous un temple ?
Voyez-vous un tombeau ? Voyez-vous une pyramide ?
Voyez-vous de potentiels dégâts ou du pillage sur un site ?
Puis vous marquerez ce qu'il y a.
Et sur le côté, il y aura toujours des exemples riches
de ce que vous voyez exactement, pour vous guider.
Toutes les données que vous nous aidez à collecter
seront partagées avec les autorités habilitées
et aideront à créer un nouveau système mondial d'alarme
pour aider à protéger les sites.
Mais cela ne s'arrêtera pas là.
Tous les archéologues avec qui nous partageons vos découvertes
vous amèneront avec eux lors de l’excavation
en utilisant Periscope, Google Plus et les médias sociaux.
Il y a cent ans, l'archéologie était pour les riches.
Il y a 50 ans,
c'était pour les hommes.
Aujourd'hui, c'est surtout pour les chercheurs.
Notre but est de démocratiser le processus de découverte archéologique
et de permettre à tout le monde de participer.
Il y a 94 ans,
Howard Carter a découvert le tombeau de Toutankhamon.
Qui sera le prochain Howard Carter ?
Peut-être vous.
En créant cette plateforme,
nous trouverons des millions d'endroits occupés par des milliards de personnes
qui nous ont précédés.
Si nous voulons répondre aux grandes questions sur notre identité
et d'où nous venons,
les réponses à ces questions ne sont pas dans les pyramides ou palaces
mais dans les villes et villages de ceux qui nous ont précédés.
Si nous voulons en savoir plus sur le passé,
il est temps d'inverser les pyramides.
Reconnaître que le passé mérite d'être préservé
est bien plus significatif.
Cela veut dire que nous méritons, aussi, d'être sauvés.
Et la meilleure histoire jamais racontée
est l'histoire de notre voyage commun en tant qu'humains.
Mais nous ne pouvons l'écrire qu'ensemble.
Venez avec moi.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)